Bonjour à tous et bienvenu dans "L'académie des Cancres n°2"
L'épisode 1 vous avait pas mal plus, il y avait quelques truc qui n'allaient pas
On les a corrigés aujourd'hui
Et avant tout disclaimer : Ne faites pas ce qu'on va faire là en cours
Parce que nous c'est pas un vrai cours ; c'est un faux cours
J'vous assure que Laink et Terracid ne sont plus du tout au lycée depuis des années
S : Quelle âge ?
T :  23 (ans)
Ah non j'ai 26
*rigole*
S : Quoi tu sais pas ton âge ?
Deux équipe vont s'affronter
Comme la dernière fois
Moi avec Maghla contre
Laink et Terracid
3 épreuves
A la fin de chaque épreuve Professeur Winston attribuera une note à chacune des 2 équipes
Le professeur a le droit de vous retirer des points si vous faites les zigotos
Si vous faites des trucs que vous n'êtes pas censés faire en cours
Il a aussi le droit de vous mettre un blâme
Si vous faites une faute grave, au bout de 3 blâmes vous allez au coin
J'vous jure que c'est pas un avantage d'être seul
dans l'académie des cancres épisode 1 et 2 *parle très vite*
L : Il va se prendre full blâmes
S : Lui, tu sens il a une tête à se prendre des blâmes
S : Professeur Winston, vous en pensez quoi ?
W : Il va s'en prendre
*tout le monde rigole*
S : Le prof qui est pas objectif
Aujourd'hui 3 épreuves :
Une épreuve de Physique-chimie, la deuxième épreuve, les amis, ce sera une épreuve d'art plastique
T : AH NON
*Rigole*
S : Troisième épreuve, les amis, comme la dernière fois une épreuve d'EPS
T'as fait du sport là bas ?
T : Ça se voit non ?
S : Oui, grave !
L : Il y a fort longtemps
S : Les amis, êtes-vous prêts à commencer ce deuxième épisode de l'académie des cancres ?
Oh oui alors ! On est vraiment pressés
*sonnerie de classe avec des enfants joyeux*
W : Alors, beh, bienvenue à tous dans cette nouvelle classe
Je ne vous connais pas du tout donc j'aimerais avoir vos prénoms sur un chevalet
T : On s'est vu avant le tournage
W : Chut !
T : Ah pardon
W : Donc un petit chevalet avec vos prénoms
S : Ok, on y va !
W : Vous avez des petites feuilles
L : J'sais plus comment on fait les chevalets
T : Monsieur, j'ai oublié ma trousse, je peux emprunter un crayon à...
...à Lui *rires*
S : Vas-y, vas-y je te le donne
W : Oui
T : Merci !
T : Tu peux m'en passer un de couleur ?
S : Oh pardon
T : T'as un blame. Monsieur il sort d'la pièce
S : Nan, nan nan, ça va pas commencer ?
T : Ah pardon
M : Mais non il lui en prête
S : C'est lui il m'demande plein de crayons
W : Ouais, bah je vais garder ce crayon
W : Tout le monde a bien son ..[rires].. chevalet ?
W : Nous passons donc a la première épreuve, qui est une épreuve de physique-chimie.
W : Pour commencer, nous allons faire une petite expérience, il va falloir gonfler un ballon
W : A l'aide de deux produits
M : Mais c'est dangereux monsieur
W : Mais on aime le risque
S : Si je puis me permettre, vous avez quand même fait un chevalet comme un enfant de 7 ans et demi
S : Vous êtes sûr que vous êtes professeur ?
*rires*
S : Pardon (x 3)
S : C'était une petite blague avant l'épreuve d'anglais, euh de français
W : Le blâme va pas tarder
S : D'accord, pardon excusez-moi *rire nerveux*
W : Donc ce que je vous propose avant toute chose
W : C'est d'équiper vos blouses qu'il y a dans vos sacs
S : Ouh
M : Rholala
W : Et après on pourra attaquer tout ça
S : Dans cette épreuve, nous allons devoir recouvrir la blouse du professeur Winston de sa couleur le plus possible
S : Et à la fin, un juge de l'académie de Versailles viendra
S : pour dire quelle couleur est la plus présente sur la blouse du professeur Winston
S : Et ce sera l'équipe qui gagnera
L : Le professeur Winston est d'accord avec ça ?
W : Nous avons une petite bouteille
W : Dans cette bouteille, nous allons mettre du vinaigre blanc
W : Voilà
W : Ensuite, on prend ce petit ballon
W : Vous en avez tous devant vous
W : Cette petite poudre blanche que vous avez chacun dans vos petits flacons devant vous
*Bruit ballon qui gonfle*
W : qu'il va falloir mettre là dedans *bruit ballon qui dégonfle*
W : Vous pouvez vous calmer un peu pendant que j'explique
S : Ah ce n'est pas moi, vous voyez bien que ce n'est pas moi
W : Alors comment mettre la poudre là dedans sans entonnoir
W : Bah vous avez des feuilles de...[ricannements]
S : Il m'a échappé des mains
W : Ouais (c'est ça)
W : Petit entonnoir, regardez vous mettez le ballon au bout
W : et ensuite on fait péter la poudre
*ricannements*
W : Attendez, j'essaye de faire tout tomber ça
W : Allez, super c'est..[ricannements]
*Rires* (surtout de Terracid)
W : Alors là il y a un blâme
M : Non non mais vous voyez bien qu'il a juste essayé de le tenir
S : Réellement, je voulais vous aider
S : Je pensais qu'il y a avait besoin de ceci dans l'expérience que vous faites
W : Il y a un blâme, y a un blâme clairement
S : Ah bon bah je vais le marquer au tableau *rires*
W : On fait ça et ensuite
W : on fait ceci
M : Wouah
*Wouah général*
W : Ce qui fait gonfler le ballon
W : Sauf que d'habitude il y a plus de poudre
W : donc c'est un peu plus impressionnant, mais euuuuh
W : Mais vous allez pouvoir mettre plus de poudre
L : Ça s'arrête là du coup
S : Voilà, donc la liste des blâmes
T : Non Monsieur, par contre si la euh c'est Poukave
T : et vous avez dit que c'était lui qui avait un blâme
W : Ah bah oui, donc vous allez avoir un 2ème blâme si vous...[bruit de flûte]
T : Triche
M : Monsieur ?
S : Attend on est cours de physique chimie ou de musique ? répondez à ma question
W : Attendez, donc y a un blâme là
W : Il y a un blâme là aussi
S : Roooh
M : Ah bah oui on est d'accord
L : Vas-y mais ferme ta gu**le
S : Merci Monsieur
S : A nous de jouer, le premier qui réussi à ça, il a sa pipette
S : Maghla t'as écouté ou pas ?
M : Ouais
S : J'ai rien écouté comme dans ma scolarité normale
L : Non mais mec il a fait des trucs avant de faire ça en fait
W : Si vous avez besoin d'aide vous me dites
T : Non ça va
S : Monsieur (x 3) il a pas ses gants
M : Il a pas ses gants
W : C'est vrai que par mesure de sécurité c'est mieux
M : Ça c'est des points en moins
T : Vous ne l'aviez pas dit en fait à la base
S : Wow, y a des...
W : Je pense qu'il y a un petit blâme qui arrive là
S : Non
M : Pardon ?
L : Oh ça y est put**n y a la masse
T : Oh oui (x 2)
L : Oh oui j'ai mis la dose
L : Hey on va les battre
T : Par contre j'arrive pas à l'enlever maintenant
S : On est en retard (x 2)
L : Oh put...oh arrête bordel de merde
M : Monsieur, on a pas de tube à essai
W : Il n'y a pas besoin de tube à essai
T : Oui, alors le précipité
W : C'est de le mettre directement dans le ballon
S : Ça c'est quoi, ça sert à rien
M : Attends, on est censés mettre ça dedans hein ?
W : Alors faut mettre le vinaigre blanc dans la bouteille
L : Tu mets tout ?
Chhuuuut
W : Ah ouais, vous mettez tout
S : Mais ils...mais Monsieur ils ont eu leur réaction chimique dans la bouteille
T : Monsieur ?
L : Elle est encore plus grosse que la vôtre
*rires*
W : Bien joué
S : elle est incroyable
T : Ah merci, hippie Hip...
S : Mais c'est pas sur nous
T : ...Hourra
S : Monsieur (x 3)
M : Monsieur c'est bon regardez
T : Euh par rapport, en taille de ballon...
M : Ben, on juge pas la taille hein
L : Hahaha, regarde la taille qu'elle fait
S : Et vous qu'est-ce que vous avez ajouter à votre expérience ?
S : Enfin vous pouvez peut-être nous expliquer
M : Monsieur regardez ils ont pas mis un peu de teinture là-bas sur la feuille. Vous voyez ?
S : Oh les gars, vous abusez de ouf
S : Vous abusez de ouf les gars
*rires*
*Squeezie chuchote quelque chose....*
W : Non mais cette expérience a très bien fonctionné
T : Monsieur excusez-moi
S : Pardon pardon
W : Ben blâme
S : Oh non put**n
S : Non put**n
T : Oh non un blâme
S : Non j'en ai marre des blâmes
W : Je vais remettre un blâme
S : Retournez-vous vite il y a un truc là-bas
T : Oui ça on l'a oublié tout à l'heure, on ne sait pas où le mettre
S : Et donc c'est quoi la suite de l'expérience du coup
T : Oh mais...
*rires*
T : Oui ?
M : Par contre Monsieur au niveau des ballons
M : Pourquoi celui-ci c'est plus rempli que l'autre ?
W : Parce qu'il y avait plus en quantité de...[rires]
M : Mais ça c'est pas toléré Monsieur
L : Il a pas fait exprès, il voulait attraper le bécher
S : Si je puis me permettre, il y a clairement un blâme du côté...
* Bruit buzz*
S : 3ÈME BLÂME
W : Oh ben dis donc
T : quel blâme ?
W : Au coin s'il vous plaît
T : C'est déjà 3 blâmes Monsieur ?
W : Oui
S : Tchao !
M : Au revoir !
T : Bon ben d'accord
L : Je prends sa place Monsieur parce qu'il a les feuilles
M : Excusez-moi Monsieur je me permets de me lever du coup par rapport au tableau *rires*
M : Du coup oui par rapport au tableau, est-ce que ça part ça ?
L : C'est tombé
W : Oui c'est de la solution aqueuse donc pas de soucis
T : Monsieur faites attention à vous
*rires*
T : Euh oui oui
W : vous allez au coin hein
T : Ah bah oui
S : Put**n
T : Maghla par contre repose cette bouteille. Tu risquerais d'avoir un accident
M : Oui pardon
W : Par contre vous êtes...
T : Oui ?
T : ...Au coin ?
T : Oui
M : Sauf que ça parle beaucoup, alors que c'est au coin
W : Ouais ouais
L : Vous parliez de l'eau
W : L'eau...dans 20-30 ans il n'y en aura plus
*rires de Squeezie et Terracid*
S : C'est ça ce prof
L : Et l'eau ça va dans les plantes
S : Ce prof en carton mon gars
L : La plante qui a derrière vous par exemple, elle a besoin d'eau ?
W : Oui ben ça...
L : C'est quelle genre de plante Monsieur ?
W : Ça c'est un ficus
W : C'est une plante d'intérieure où on peut les...
L : D'accord
W : ...les feuilles...
*rires*
W : Ce qui est con, c'est que je viens de vous voir en train de me jeter du produit sur moi tous les 2
W : Donc vous avez un blâme chacun
M : Pardon ?
L : Monsieur
W : Ah bah bravo en plus grâce à vous...vous avez...
*Cassage de matériel par Terracid*
Han (général)
*Rires de Squeezie*
T : Monsieur ?
L : Gros con va
T : Monsieur euh *rires*
S : Alors là, alors là si je puis me permettre
W : Vous savez quoi ? Vous sortez de cours
S : Wouah ! (général)
W : vous allez voir le proviseur, vous allez dans son bureau
S : J'suis délégué, je peux l'accompagner au CPE
W : Oui bien sûr
W : Alors, nous allons parler du tableau périodique
W : Je connais par coeur le tableau périodique
M : Aaaah !
S : C'est fait je peux me rasseoir du coup ? Je l'ai déjà raccompagné. Il est au CPE là
W : Ok, si vous restez sage
S : Quel est l'élément périodique n°4 du tableau des éléments ?
W : Le....
....nucléus
*rires*
W : Ah vous avez quand même mis tout ça dans un beau...un bel état
L : Là Monsieur vous l'avez vu
W : C'était ingénieux
L : Vous l'avez vu non ?
*rires*
L : Et du coup il a pas de blâme ?
W : Ben si clairement
L : Ah !
T : Monsieur c'est bon il y a le CPE qui m'a fait un mot
W : "C'est bon peut revenir"
W : Ok vous pouvez revenir à votre place
T : Merci Monsieur
S : Non Monsieur vous pouvez pas...
M : Il n'y a pas de signature
S : Monsieur vous voyez bien qu'il a ouvert son bloc-notes et qu'il a marqué "c'est bon"
T : Non non, ben sinon je l'aurais signé "Damien" si c'était moi
L : Poukave
S : Ouais ok c'est vrai t'as raison
S : Les amis c'est la fin de cette épreuve de physique chimie
S : Le dos a été pas mal touché durant cette épreuve
S : et il est maintenant temps de voir quelle couleur est la plus présente sur la blouse du professeur Winston
S : pour savoir quelle équipe a gagné ce round
S : c'est clairement le rose
M : Bah oui de toute évidence
T : Non (x 3)
M : Mais bien sûr que si, regardez devant il y a du rose aussi
S : Alors Maghla....Excusez-moi (x2)
S : Les gars (x 2) Maghla elle a une.....
M : Attendez !
S : Wow (x 3) il se passe quoi là  wow *Squeezie tente de faire taire tout le monde*
M : Je ne suis pas d'accord
T : Quels sont les arguments ?
M : Regardez, les couleurs rose et bleu = violet
M : On a l'impression qu'il y a plus de bleu alors qu'en fait c'est du rose
M : Là où il y a du violet, c'est du rose du coup
S : Je n'ai rien compris Maghla je suis désolé
S : Je suis obligée de te dire que je n'ai rien compris
S : Il y avait trop de couleurs à la seconde
M : Et dès qu'il y a du violet, ça veut dire qu'il y a du rose
M : Donc il y a tellement plus de violet
T : Non non là, il y a beaucoup plus de bleu